I got a little bit of a game for you
guys today we're gonna play around of
our movie version of which you rather so
it's picking between two things and then
explaining why you would choose one or
the other so first off would you rather
screw up every take yourself or have
somebody else screw up your best take
that's tough oh that's
I'd rather screw up every take myself if
it means I still get to use my best take
whoa does that reveal something horrible
about behind you get the best of both
worlds there so I understand I think I
have to steal that because that's so
good okay would you rather work with a
director who gives you too many notes or
not enough too many oh if they're good
notes
I'll take them if the but if they're bad
notes I would rather have none now your
work in the game a little bit okay okay
you're right I want to have it always I
know this is like a yes or no game and
I'm I'm budging I understand why when it
comes to motion capture duh do you have
more room to play there than you do
let's say when you're doing the
live-action material you know I want to
say maybe so I want to say it depends
but I mean in the sense of you're not
limited really to where you walk I mean
you can be because that would be like
you're here did it on it uh but you know
you have a freedom in the acting I think
that you don't always get live action
because if you do something fabulous and
your back happens to be turned later he
can have the camera on you
although if this is your first time
doing CGI and motion capture then you
will not understand how it translates
and you may make some master if you had
to give someone out there trying it this
for the very first time just one point
or one tip to ease them into it what
would it be I would give them the advice
that Steve gave that I did not take to
heart as much as I should have which is
that you do not need to play it as a
doll at all that will be done for you
and do it as naturally and most
inhumanly as as possible and I for some
reason did not really ingest in
metabolism
is that and kind of put a hat on a hat
she's lying she's so good in the film
mind would you rather work on a set with
no food or no caffeine
oh no no food I cannot go without the
caffeine yeah I finally found two people
who are on the same page as me yeah I
mean yeah caffeine is everything would
you rather do a scene where you have to
eat the entire scene or run throughout
the entire scene I can't do either of
these things I didn't say I could do it
Oh all right I would rather I'd rather
be able to Lana for an entire scene no
that's a fair bit better at eating but
yeah I feel like you never really think
about how many times you have to do the
eating scenes over and over and over and
then it's not funny I always think about
you know because I don't eat so many
things I think Oh what would I do
I think about how good James Gandolfini
was in the Sopranos hit eating he just
made you wanna eat you made you eat
whatever it was is so badly the toughest
one or at least what I think is the
toughest one would you rather have to
fake sneeze or fake vomit in a scene
fake sneeze but it's tough just because
the retching could get tough on the
throat I have a hard time imagining
myself doing a convincing fake sneeze
though I'm not gonna do it I know I know
it's like that was really good and you
almost I almost let that like needy
actor love me you know see the montage
of fake sneezes I've accumulated over
the last two years you did it set it's
good fix are really good that's a good
one to switch gears just to wrap this up
quickly but so this movie is very marked
story in this movie is very very
specific but the whole idea of just
emotional healing through art is so
universal so do you guys have any
hobbies and artistic hobby anything like
that that kind of helps you center
yourself hmm I don't have any hobbies I
just work but I think that's a hobby
that counts yeah yeah I don't find
acting centering unfortunately I wish I
did when I was a kid I had a dollhouse
and I loved that and maybe there was
something cathartic
having that yeah
you